Hi.
Thank you for having me.
How is it?
Your beautiful,
almost one year old?
She is, she just turned nine months.
So it's, I mean,
she's just the cutest little angel I've ever seen,
and I'm obsessed with her,
as I'm sure most parents say about their children,
and it's the most fun role
and experience that I've ever had.
And I love absolutely every single minute of it,
it's been such a joy.
She's perfect.
And you are married to Chris Pratt,
who is just, I mean
I've had luckily enough, the fortune
and privilege of meeting him a couple times.
He is always the nicest human being.
He has the best reputation.
Everybody loves him.
He's like the coolest human on the planet.
When you met him,
How long was it before
you're like, you're the one?
I mean, we also, we talk about that a lot
because I'm pretty sure we both,
we both knew right away that that's,
that you know, this is where our relationship was headed,
and we clicked, you know, very quickly.
And, and so he's the best, and I'm so, so grateful
and it's so beautiful to be able to watch him, you know,
step into this new role of being a girl dad
and he's the best husband and best dad.
And I feel so grateful every single day for him.
I am so happy for you.
It's so wonderful to hear good people in the world
happy, you know?
Thank you.
Happiness is one of
the greatest blessings,
and I am on a new mission to really talk about
the power of forgiveness.
What was the catalyst for you to approach this subject
and put it at the forefront in this extraordinary book?
Well, thank you.
I mean, I think that for me, forgiveness,
the interest in forgiveness really came
when I realized that I was really struggling
with forgiveness and my inability to practice it.
And I also didn't really know what it meant to me.
And it really just was so helpful
to me to be able to hear other people's experiences
and to hear how people have struggled with it
and some still struggle with it,
and how some people have been able to practice it.
And also you don't really talk about it,
yet we all will experience it at some point in our lives.
And I feel really lucky
that it's been able to be helpful for other people as well.
There I something, really, for everyone in this book.
And I just want to thank you for leading the charge
on helping people find an ability to
do such a courageous, important, and liberating act.
And I know you also partnered
with the baby probiotic company in Vivo
is that how I pronounce it?
Yeah. In vivo, it's crazy because, you know,
when I think a lot about just being a new mom
and teaching her about so many things
and also being taught about so many things,
and one of the things that I learned about was
newborn gut deficiency
which actually impacts over 90% of babies born in America.
And that's just a lack of good bacteria in baby's guts.
And it's crazy because we always hear
about like, diaper rash, and colic in newborn babies.
And we think that's normal,
but the reality is that has a lot to do
with just an imbalanced gut.
And so just being able to have the ability to work
with a company like in vivo
and give an infant probiotic is just really incredible.
And I've had such a great experience with it
but it's like one of those things that I want to share
with all new moms to be able to research
about newborn gut deficiency
but then also just be able to give it to their babies.
And you have an Instagram series
before, during and after baby.
Will you tell us about that?
Yeah, it's been so incredible.
I recently did one
with my mom for mother's day, which was hilarious,
but I, I've had such a great time doing it.
And I, it's all things before, during after baby.
So we talk about everything, from fertility, to pregnancy,
to labor, relationships, sex, newborn gut deficiency,
really just all the different topics that we
want to know more about.
And we have guts, guests come on
and talk about all these subjects.
And we do it every Thursday at noon.
And it's been such a fun experience for me.
And I'm learning so much as a new mom.
So it's also really beneficial that way.
Well, thank goodness for that.
And also I was so excited to talk
about this book and I know it's new out in paperback,
"The Gift of Forgiveness: Inspiring Stories
from Those Who Have Overcome the Unforgivable."
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you,
Katherine Schwarzenegger-Pratt!
(upbeat rock music)